Сто двадцять тисяч строковиків. Саме стільки мають призвати до армії Росії в рамках осіннього призову.
У міноборони РФ наголосили, що призовників на війну в Україну відправляти не будуть.
Але закону, який забороняє це робити, у Росії нема.
У Росії немає жодного нормативного документа, який забороняє відправлення строковиків у зону бойових дій.
Єдине обмеження - це в положенні про проходження військової служби, затвердженої указом президента,
те, що строковики можуть бути направлені до зони бойових дій лише через 4 місяці
після їхнього призову на військову службу та отримання первинної військово-облікової спеціальності.
Теоретично строковиків можуть відправити в Україну вже на початку весни, кажуть експерти.
І хоча поки що масово призовників на фронт ще не перекидали,
про окремі такі випадки стало відомо ще на самому початку війни.
Але частіше у російській армії практикують інше - на передову відправляють тих, хто щойно відслужив строкову.
Це поширена практика, коли строковиків змушують або пропонують підписувати контракт.
Я буквально вчора розмовляв зі строковиком, який недавно демобілізувався,
запитував його: вас змушували підписувати контракт?
Ні, не змушували, але пропонували.
Така робота йде скрізь, з різним ступенем тиску.
Десь дійсно примусово робиться, через силу, погрозами.
А десь чисто формально - хочеш, не хочеш - ну, і не треба.
Із початком осіннього призову збіглося й оголошення про закінчення мобілізаційних заходів у Росії.
Про це спочатку повідомили у Міноборони Росії, а згодом підтвердив прес-секретар Путіна Дмитро Пєсков.
При цьому указ про закінчення мобілізації Путін не підписав.
Правозахисники вважають це головним свідченням того, що її не закінчено.
Потрібно дивитися на ті нормативні документи, які є й опубліковані,
і настав час не довіряти навіть голослівним твердженням президента і міністра оборони.
Тому що 21 вересня опубліковано указ президента про мобілізацію, і все.
Цим указом її оголошено, і де-юре вона продовжується.
Формально осінній призов та мобілізація можуть відбуватися паралельно, розповідають експерти.
Для цього немає юридичних перешкод. Щоправда, є проблеми технічного характеру.
Цьому нічого не заважає. Інша справа, що навряд чи військкомати впораються
одночасно з потоком і призовників, і мобілізованих.
Наприклад, щоб призвати у військкоматі в якомусь регіоні 3 тисячі осіб на строкову службу,
потрібно прогнати через структури Міноборони, через військові комісаріати втричі більше людей,
тому що там велика кількість тих, хто навчається і має відстрочки,
хто не придатний за станом здоров'я, кому потрібно перевіряти ще раз стан здоров'я.
У Кремлі тим часом повідомили, що жодного указу для завершення мобілізації непотрібно.
Водночас російські депутати розробили законопроєкт,
який передбачає кримінальне покарання для ухилянтів - до 5 років позбавлення волі.
Тим часом мобілізація, яка призвела до масового виїзду з РФ працездатних росіян,
уже негативно відбивається на російській економіці.
Російський ринок праці знаходиться в особливо цікавому становищі, в якому він не знаходився ніколи,
тому що, з одного боку, є пряме відрахування з трудової сили мобілізованих,
а, з іншого боку, є також пряме відрахування з трудової сили тих, що виїхали.
І це, перш за все, креативний клас, освічені люди, які рухають продуктивність,
рухають галузі, які спритні, які заповзятливі, активні та молоді.
При цьому російський ринок праці страждає не лише через масовий від'їзд співробітників айті-сфери та креативних галузей.
Серйозним шоком для нього став і дефіцит малокваліфікованих кадрів.
Ці роботи традиційно виконували чоловіки з бідніших верств населення, які нині воюють проти України.
При цьому експерти визнають, що нині ще надто мало даних для проведення адекватного аналізу наслідків мобілізації.
Раніше кварталу ви не дізнаєтеся жодних цифр навіть більш-менш приблизних.
Бо незрозуміло навіть скільки мобілізованих. Хтось оцінює, що їх 500 тисяч, а хтось каже, що мобілізація закінчилася.
І те, й інше брехня. Відверта. Відповідно, чи то 700 тисяч, чи то мільйон виїхали.
Але питання не в тому, що вони поїхали.
Якщо вони виїхали і, як і раніше, обслуговують клієнтів у Росії,
то фундаментально для економіки це впливає тільки на супутній бізнес.
На оренду квартир, продаж автомобілів.
Вони зараз на 65 відсотків упали.
Пропозиція на ринку нерухомості зросла втричі.
Експерти відзначають і ще один важливий аспект:
мобілізація також вдарила по внутрішньому попиту в Росії, що вплине на торгівлю.
В умовах невизначеності росіяни вважають за краще економити гроші.